head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts SC cnr.com
scotus denies Jack Smith's request to
FastTrack judgment on Trump's immunity
claims the order jeopardizes a special
council's proposed March 4th start date
this is basically it Donald Trump's vict
in a single very short sentence the
petition for a RIT of sirari before
judgment is denied there you go what
this means is Donald Trump is appealing
he's arguing that he is immune as
president and I believe the the
arguments presented excuse me by legal
Scholars sound that a president does a
lot of things if you think the president
has committed High crimes and
misdemeanors treas and Sedition whatever
it might be you impeach them convict
them and then criminally charge them the
reason why we don't criminally charge
sitting presidents is that they are the
chief enforcer of law as the head of the
executive branch that means that we
first have to remove them from the
position of law enforcement before we
criminally charge them I think it makes
total sense right now what we're seeing
is it looks like this case the federal
level is not going to happen until after
the election because of this and what
that likely means is Trump will pardon
himself that would be the best move of
all time I think so funny realistic I
feel like we're going to jump through
some more legal hurdles before we get
there but uh it would make the Democrats
crazy if we got to the point where Trump
pardoned himself was he going to be like
pardon me and then it'll be like well
all right he said it that actually does
seem like something Donald Trump would
do he'd be he he'd stand up and he
smarking to go pardon me can you can you
do that can the president pardon them
you just put it on Truth social I am
pardoned and that's it wow he would just
say pardon me that's a good one F I'm
not asking I'm telling I'm pardoning
these signs uh I think 2024 is going to
be just balls of the wall crazy wild I
think all bets are off it's impossible
to predict we were fasten your seat
belts we were talking with uh Eric
Prince earlier this morning founder of
Blackwater and you know that's one of
the questions I had you know with his
experience in uh conflict crisis and you
know foreign war and all that stuff for
all the criticisms I think his Insight
still matters what would it be like like
is is the potential there do you see the
signs and he was just saying
that he basically said gradually then
suddenly that with a lot of the
countries they've seen in crisis even
during Katrina United States it is
overnight your utilities are gone this
one of the scariest things I think
people don't realize and what he said
was when his guys got to uh uh to uh um
New Orleans from during
Katrina when they arrived they were dead
bodies all over the place killed by
lutters and I said I don't know if
looter is the right word Bandit maybe
Barbarian you know when when people
people take all of our we talked about
high TR Society they take it for granted
when the president of the United States
his authority his position is questioned
and challenged that is someone taking a
hammer in a chisel and striking it into
the stone foundation of this country in
this way particularly and if confidence
in the system
shatters gradually as we're seeing and
then suddenly overnight electricity's
off food's not at your store anymore
internet's not working you don't know
what's going on in a circumstance like
that the last place I'd want to be is
like New York Chicago or La I wouldn't
mind just being on the mountain in West
Virginia with some chickens and from
what I've been told if that kind of
thing were to happen and it was a
utility situation you got about three
weeks that you're going to need to
survive on your own and then things will
probably come back but in those three
weeks if you're not prepared not if it's
a civil war not if it turns into
something like that but if it's like a
grid down situation and it's like you've
got a lot of death in the first two
weeks people that aren't prepared at all
and but if you're one of those prepared
people and you're able to like hold out
you should be okay have you guys heard
of a book called 1 second after have you
ever read read this book it's about an
electromagnetic pulse and what happens
to civilization all breaks down within a
few hours when there's no electricity
just what happens and it basically
devolves into Lord of the Flies into
just Anarchy and after a few days people
start breaking out into tribes y it's
it's crazy you got to read that book I
think you see early signs of that right
now though right we we see communities
at odds with each other every day I mean
I just saw the story today where Charlie
Sheen the actor his neighbor like broke
into his house and tried to strangle him
like people are at odds with one another
every single day there might be other
circumstances there but I think it's
fair to say that trust has degraded
enough to affect Quality of Life as we
know it right now just think about how
crazy it was like in the 1800s where
you're some dude who has a farm and you
could be in a feud with a guy like 50
mil away and then he just go over there
kill him and then go back and then
nobody would know I mean this was uh you
never do anything about it what's the
prequel to is it 1889 the like
Yellowstone prequel they off this whole
thing where it's like well we want that
land for our sheep to graze on okay well
we'll come and murder you like they have
shootouts all the time it it it's not as
far back as we think it is right in that
one it's like they were close enough to
the city to where there were questions
about the feud and everything but back
in the day some guy would jump out of
the forest stab you take your stuff and
there ain't no way no's going to figure
out happened I was going to Tweet out I
Didn't Do It CU kind of ridiculous how
many people do you think have died I'm
just talking about of all of all time
yeah oh there's a number you can Google
it really yeah course but like you said
you can't track it cuz some people just
they disappear that's not true we have
uh 109 billion people have lived and
died over the course of 192,000 years uh
it's it's an estimate obviously but it's
just simply tracking population size and
growth and we know about population
sizes through historical record except
for
tartaria right that was another 100
billion oh sh never Foria yeah let's
let's talk more um well I think this is
a year of doing your best and
maintaining friendships it's going to be
so important to be tight with who you're
tight with and stay tight you know we're
having this discussion with uh uh
Michael malice because he got that bet
with Roseanne and uh what's the bet
Roseanne said there won't be an election
Michael M said I will bet you $1,000
there will be and she said deal she also
bet there would be military tribunals at
the end of this year that Trump would be
arresting people and he laughed and he
bet and I'm like Rosanne that's that's
not going to happen now the question
about election is what do you mean by no
election I think we all agree she meant
it would like chaos the election
wouldn't happen and uh who was was it
colonel McGregor who no it wasn't who
was it who said that we're not going to
make it to 2024's election you might be
right about that I'm not you want to
look it up on a podcast it was on pbd I
think and uh uh I I actually think
there's a strong case for that and we
joke with Michael malice that he doesn't
owe Roseanne any money because just
because Trump's been removed from the
ballot doesn't mean there won't be an
election and uh Michael was arguing that
if it's Nikki Haley versus Joe Biden
it's still an election and I'm like Fair
Point agreed but I'm starting to feel
like if it does I'm saying if it
escalates based on everything we're
seeing by May or June the damn could
snap I mean they're they're talking
about putting the city the former
president I almost said sitting the
former president in prison and 74
million voters more more votes than any
sitting president this is not going to
this is not going to it's not going to
work I mean people are just going to go
insane January 6 already happened they
can make any argument they want about
yeah but the government will stop them
whatever I'm like dude what what what
Eric Prince was talking about this
morning you got to understand that uh he
said even police in Louisiana are
looting and we talked about this I said
there was a movie and the uh the crew
the audience the chat pointed out World
War Z Brad Pitt's character goes into
the store to get medicine for his
daughter he sees a cop run in and he's
like oh crap and the cop just looks at
him starts grabbing stuff and then runs
cops are people so when it when it if it
breaks down to this point it's not just
going to be the military being like we
are going to stop all of this yo they
were cops active duty and they were
active duty military on January 6 in the
capital it's not like everybody in the
Army is just like a bunch of liberals
yeah it's not like everybody that's
wearing a cop uniform is going to be a
cop either yeah exactly um I I got a one
of those bow Fang CB radios those little
$20 you know handheld rad shortwave
radios and a little solar panel got some
solar panels I mean if if grid down we
need to maintain communication that's
primary number one I don't know exactly
the rules and restrictions of that cuz
they'll be like stay off of these
channels you can't go on these channels
and I think the thing is if if we were
to go grid down this is the time that
you would want to know your neighbors
and know who's going to be in the houses
next door to you because there's one
thing to say like yes we should all flee
to the woods but realistically if you
live in Suburbia if you live in a city
you're not going to be able to get out
fast enough if the gr grid G grid goes
down you have to know the people around
you and that's really the big crime of
American culture today which is that we
are more isolated than ever and we are
low trust so we are unlikely to reach
out to the people next door to us and
therefore we're surrounding ourselves
with strangers why do you think people
feel low trust I mean this is something
they've documented over time right like
the we are not a community- based people
we are not as involved in community
service we don't attend church as much
and so I think it's just sort of um a
cultural shift some of it I would argue
has to do with values right uh you can
say we all have the same values but
unless you live and breathe the values
we don't really know what they are and I
think also we are are more divided
Society politically and so we are taught
to train to look at everyone who doesn't
vote the same way we do as the other and
that's uh an unrealistic way to live
trust is everything trust is confidence
a government only exists based on trust
I'm not saying trust as in if Ian tells
me he'll pay me back I trust he will
that's a component but trust is also I
know that if I break the law I can trust
in government to punish me or someone
else I know that if someone tries to
break into my house I can trust that the
police will be there low trust Society
doesn't just mean we have faith in each
other it means do we have faith in this
system and as we're moving closer and
closer to or as as trust and Society is
dropping rapidly it will eventually come
to a point where it's no different than
if there was no government so when you
know Eric Prince is mentioning their
guys show up after being called in by
the government saying we need security
and they find dead bodies that's a zero
trust Society random guys with guns
don't care who you are don't want to
bother with it they're hungry and they
need stuff and you're in the way you die
that could happen gradually as well as
you know hurricane comes floods the city
everyone's in panic and Chaos the system
is broken law enforcement is in is
disheveled and looting and running no so
trust is gone the problem is I think
that some people are they kind of are
waiting for it to happen and are like
ready for the moment the power goes down
to just jump like another George Floyd
riots uh Summer of Love kind of thing
exactly like they're not even going to
wait two days to before they're just
like we are so that I'm very concerned
about that they're already doing it we
are seeing the videos over the past
several years of people just storming
into buildings and raing them and taking
whatever they want and it's and you know
what it is there's trust in this they
trust the government will do nothing to
stop them they trust no one will stop
them so the government will uh I should
say law enforcement will arrest you for
illegally bearing guns they describe as
illegal I think the Constitution says
otherwise and then when the criminals
come and Rob and destroy your property
they say what are we supposed to do
about it so the system is designed to
fail right now there we're already at
the point of almost no trust what
happens in the summer of this year when
it's looking like Donald Trump will win
or they take action to in some way stop
Donald Trump from winning Eric Prince
pointed out the only other time the
Democrats a president had been removed
from the ballot and it was Democrats who
did it was Abraham Lincoln a year later
the country was in a civil war VI made
an interesting tweet uh I think it was
yesterday he said if you think that
Donald Trump or Joe Biden are getting
anywhere near the White House what is
wrong with you like the way he phrased
it was like there's no way in hell
that's going to happen Trump or Biden
yeah he's kind of like I think he's he
sees something about the way that the
Deep State works and the way that the
powers of be kind of want the situation
to go and they are the ones with all the
secret police so he just kind of
consigned himself to it I don't know if
the Tweet still up I'm looking for it
it's about about you sure it's a real
tweet uh someone just made a fake one
here it is it's from 20 hours AG go from
VI on his page if you really if you
really think quote they are going to let
either Trump or Biden get anywhere near
the Finish Line open your eyes folks
there's something deeper going on it's
starting it's staring us right in the
face but who is they though yeah who is
they put it in quotes thank you yay for
giving us that M and it it's could be
way bigger than the American deep state
it could be even bigger than that who
knows but does I mean we have to ask yay
who is they though uh I think one of the
problems with tweets like this is like
and I I think V is an interesting guy
you know I respect what he's doing I
think one of the problems is it's not
solution oriented I wish there was a
little bit more towards like there is
something deeper going on and I think
that's that's our big problem right now
is that people are are ready to panic
but we you when there's an issue you
have to remain calm and and come up with
a solution what I like about the tweet
and I kind of agree with you it's not a
solution oriented tweet is that he's
kind of like hey don't follow that
dangling carrot that's kind of what that
tweet read to me thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net